what we first get back to our top story
as we are joined by North Carolina
congressman Mark meadows Ohio
Congressman Jim Jordan both leaders of
the freedom caucus all right Jim I'll
start with you tonight sir and so this
is what we get yeah a man's life ruined
all of these other people have committed
crimes that we know of the information
obtained on General Flint was obtained
illegally
okay they put his family through hell he
has to sell his house they threatened
his family or he falls on the sword and
and signed something he knows is not
true so they don't go after his family
is that justice in America no it's not
and your monologue was right on target
Sean remember James Comey director of
the FBI fire deputy director McCabe lied
three times under oath fired chief
counsel at the FBI Jim Baker demoted
then left
FBI counsel Lisa page demoted then left
and deputy head of counterintelligence
Peter struck demoted then fired but even
those five people thought Mike Flynn
didn't lie when he was interviewed by
the FBI only Bob Muller did and now this
is what happened so we got to keep this
in context the top people at the FBI all
demoted left or fired who launched and
ran the Clinton investigation launched
and ran the Russian investigation put
the fake dossier in front of the FISA
Court to get a warrant to spy on the
Trump campaign even they didn't think
Mike Flynn lied when he was being
interviewed by the FBI and now Bob
Muller is saying he should get the
leanest most lenient sentence possible
but they still have the information he
gave him we'll find out what that is
when we get the unredacted version of
what catherine was referring to tonight
listen but I'm looking seriously mark
meadows through all of this here and
what they're saying here days prior to
the FB i--'s interview the defendant
Washington Post published a story
alleging he had spoken with Russia's
ambassador to the United States on
December 29th wouldn't it be a normal
process for an incoming director such as
general Flynn to have conversations with
his soon-to-be counterparts about
important issues even a change of policy
that might be coming or different points
of view that they may
have considering we have diametrically
opposed views between Obama and
president Trump well it would be a
natural occurrence and I can tell you
there are Democrats and Republicans on
the hill that probably have had a lot
more conversations with the Russian
ambassador than Mike Flynn ever thought
about having and and and yet here we are
tonight looking at a three-star general
being held guilty for missing a date and
perhaps not recalling something but
here's the other thing that we've got to
remember Sean is this I've looked at
this report and yes everybody's going to
focus on what has been redacted but
let's look at what's not in there there
is no suggestion that Michael Flynn had
anything to do with collusion he was
with the transition team he was part of
the campaign and yet there's no mention
of collusion I think it's good news for
President Trump tonight that this is
what has come down to even though they
said he's substantially cooperated
I think he's substantially cooperated to
say that there was no collusion and we
can look at it with that in mind well
let me look Jim Jordan I'll read to you
the posts query of whether the
defendants actions violated the Logan
act the Logan Act is 18 USC 953 it's old
but a rarely invoked federal statute
prohibiting unauthorized private
diplomacy with foreign nations it is net
I think maybe what five or six times
it's been used and most instances the
people get off innocent so this is what
they're they're suggesting in in this
and that he was speaking you know as
part of the the president's incoming
team transition team that they had
spoken to the defendant that he denied
speaking to the Russian ambassador about
sanctions which the president had
already said publicly if I'm not
mistaken
yet that in fact oh there's no you know
that that's probably gonna be what our
policy is that's it that this is what
this is about no III know and it when
you look at the larger framework of
course first of all he's a national
security adviser of course he's gonna be
talking to foreign dignitaries that's
that's going to be and he's going to be
doing that in the transition and you're
exactly white right what the president
had said earlier but I keep trying to
bring this back to into a context the
guy
we need to talk to Shawn while the left
is making all kinds of hay out of this
in this story tonight about mr. Flynn
the guy we need to be talking to is rod
Rosenstein it has been 10 and a half
weeks since it was reported that he
talked to subordinates about wearing a
wire and invoking the 25th amendment and
mark and I and other members of Congress
have yet to be able to ask him one
single question since that became public
that needs to happen in the next twenty
six days before Nancy Pelosi is Speaker
of the House that's what I'm focused on
this is news tonight I get it and we've
walked through this but that's the real
thing we have to focus on in the last
few weeks of this Congress let me go
back to mark Meadows congressman if you
go back to the House Intelligence
Committee report call me testified that
FBI agents so saw no physical
indications of deception now that
includes McCabe that includes Comey and
that includes Peter Strock of all people
that interviewed him they didn't think
he lied and yeah you know and this sends
a very bad message to everybody and that
is boy you better never talk to the FBI
even though you might be inclined
because you have I grew up with
reverence for this great institution you
better never unless you're a Democrat
that you can say anything you want but
then you you're covered that's what I
take out of it
well I I think here's the it's not just
in the house Intel Jim and I have been
part of testimony and briefings and
questioning where that was reiterated
not once not twice but three different
times that they didn't believe that Mike
Flynn lied so so here's here's what
we've got we've got a situation where
we're a year and a half into this
investigation it started back in May of
2017 and here we are in December if this
is the best we've got coming out of
Muller's investigation it is time that
he writes the report closes it out and
let the American people focus on what is
important to them which is really about
making sure they keep their jobs in the
economy and what the president has been
delivering on so it's time for Moeller
to bring it to a close hopefully this is
the beginning of the end but it can come
none too soon for most Americans
it's amazing to me Jim as I read through
this they're quoting The Washington Post
I'll give you one example and then they
talk again about 18 USC 953 that's the
Logan Act and subsequent to the poet
they they literally quote The Washington
Post and an article prior to the
defendants FBI interview members of
president-elect Trump's transition team
I think they might be talking about vice
president Pence publicly stated that
they had spoken to the defendant that he
denied speaking to the Russian
ambassador about the sanctions look I
don't know what your guys lives are like
I can tell you what my life is like the
number of conversations I have on a
daily basis if you asked me who I talked
to yesterday I will not be able to
recall with any sense of certainty
most people live busy lives I was there
I watched this this was as busy at a
time as anything else and I'm sure there
were a lot of pleasantries given back
and forth lipoma to working for you you
know we're gonna work on a lot of issues
together which would seem perfectly
appropriate to me yeah look and if they
thought he said something that wasn't
accurate why not circle back with him
after all he served our country was a
three-star general
why not circle back with him and as
we've pointed out several times
the FBI these key people the same FBI
who I think took something to the FISA
Court that they didn't check out
themselves that's those same people said
we didn't think he was misleading us at
all but if there was some kind of
question give that circle back to the
general and find out instead of using it
to get the information that looks like
mr. Muller was trying to get you know
one of the other things one other thing
you know one other thing that we've got
to realize Jim and I have been in these
interviews in testimony there is a whole
lot more that we can look at in terms of
the the conversations that the FBI
agents and previous agents have had they
call into question whether they're being
true for or not then what we see with
with general Flynn and this Logan act
it's a relic of a bygone era it was
meant to design and design to say we
want to make sure you're speaking on
behalf of a legitimate government it's
time that we look at this in a very
different light yeah all right I think
we have to look at it a different way
I just gave you mark of a list we just
laid it out for Sharon Mills
umma Abidine all these people that lied
before Congress all of them we know that
they lied then we have Hillary Clinton
we James Comey wrote this exoneration
and early May with Peter struck he lied
and said he wasn't beginning the writing
of that exoneration that's a lie by him
by the way he also might have issues
with the Espionage Act when he leaked
the information to his professor friend
for the very purpose of getting it to
the New York Times so that might spark
the appointment of a special counsel he
should have the same legal Jeopardy's
Hillary's you know mom-and-pop shop
bathroom closet server we believe at
least six foreign entities hacked into
it we know it's a violation of the
Espionage Act we know that her aides
emailed that very site and had email
addresses from that site I don't see any
of them going through what a 33-year
veteran five years a combat veteran has
gone through guy that served his country
to you I why is there this double
standard well there is a double standard
and it means that if you're associated
with the Trump team the Trump campaign
and the Trump administration you come
under greater scrutiny than a lot of
other people that have been here and
playing the game here in Washington DC
that must come to an end it will come to
an end guys like Jim and I are willing
to hold him accountable but enough with
the talk
let's get rod Rosenstein in here and
make sure that he testifies and actually
tells the American people what he said
or didn't say I have a tape of we played
it the other night Jim Jordan of of
James Comey literally say well I lie you
know I've lied and and McCabe lied but
you can still lie and be a good person
the exact words of James Coleman Sean
James Comey was saying he didn't want to
come testify in a closed-door session
with Congress because of leaks this is
the guy who leaked the information to
the New York Times to create the
momentum for the special counsel so come
on
mark is exactly right you're exactly
right there's two standards one for us
regular folk a different set of you're
part of the political establishment
that's what drives Americans crazy all
right thank you both freedom caucus
members mark meadows Jim Jordan we
appreciate it